[Music]
I'm a city boy I'm from New York never
seeing in a cow or anything like that
hanging out with EMU it's pretty cool
and probably won't have an opportunity
like that in rest of my life
[Music]
we are at the Monroe County Sheriff's
Office Animal Farm on the grounds of the
Detention Center we have the capacity to
have 700 inmates in all three of our
jail facilities this is the main jail
and we're the only facility of this kind
in the country that has a exotic
seriatim day it started out with just
farm animals and now I have exotic
animals of all varieties kinkajous are
from the rainforests of Central and
South America
that's the bird we call the I love you
bird and he is such a camera hog we only
take in animals that have been abandoned
abused confiscated or donated hi Tucker
we don't purchase any of the animals and
they're here for their life this is a
forever home for them I'm in here just
for a year you know and these guys are
doing a life sentence I'm oh all right
Kramer's gonna wake you up pretty girl
today I have four inmates every day they
come down here to feed water and clean
and then to spend time with the animals
what's going on buddy you're going to
get out pretty soon
mandatory rec the form is one of the
jobs in this facility that you could
actually be outside all day and number
two get to interact with a bunch of
cool animals like Kramer here he's got
the little curl on the top of his head
that's why we call him Kramer
this is Eeyore he was uh he was saved
from a slaughterhouse and he's a lot
better off genic working with animals
helps the inmates with their
rehabilitation I've seen a lot of very
positive changes I've seen people that
come down here and are completely scared
of animals and by the end of their time
here then you have them bring their
families back to actually show them what
they were doing when they were
incarcerated I'm so happy to be out here
when I first came he was like not even
this Big Piney and now look at you
[Music]
Walter pepper and chili Lavinia Billy
Idol
mahooty Stevie Wonder opus sloly
top hat right now I think I have about
36 turtles I'm Laurie Kramer
I'm the turtle lady of Manhattan I'm the
only wildlife rehabilitator in the city
that works just specifically with
Turtles I Rehab turtles in an apartment
in New York City bringing Turtles into
the country illegally has become big
business
I get Turtles from the Department of
Environmental Conservation US Fish and
Wildlife the urban park rangers even by
policemen last summer I had 680 baby
turtles that were brought here from the
Department of Environmental Conservation
it's overwhelming to have a large amount
of turtles in a New York City apartment
I promised my husband a bathroom and a
bedroom without Turtles the back
bathroom is where we take our showers
and the people bathroom if I looked
outside the city and I had a yard I
probably would be rehabilitating all
kinds of wild animals but here in
Manhattan turtles are perfect when I was
a child there was no place for women in
bed school but somehow things come full
circle I'm a turtle nurse that's
basically it I think that I did good
turtle points in heaven
[Music]
what I love about saying bats is just
how graceful they are the way they fly
they flip they flutter they move they're
just stunning
it was just kind of a love at first
sight that has stayed with me my entire
life they're just part of my world
I am Kerstin Alby mud the executive
director and founder of Missouri bat
census and I'm a bat lady
when we heard word in 2006 about white
nose syndrome I knew that we had a very
short window white nose syndrome is a
fungus it grows on a bats nose on its
wings on its tail anywhere where the bat
doesn't have fur it causes it to wake
too many times from its winter
hibernation sleep they may hang where
they're at in a cave and just starve to
death or fly out on a cold day and will
be lost on the landscape
see these little blotches in this wing
that's what we're looking for
it also invades a bats wings tissue and
it eats away at their wings okay but
it's almost spring Betty you've got a
chance to make it some of your roomies
did not survive see how we have a dead
bat here another bat right there another
good-sized one there it's really hard
not just because I enjoy the caving that
I enjoy the bats themselves and I just
want to do everything to protect them
and help them hang on till we find some
method that we can intervene on their
behalf
[Music]
we began our bat rescue and rehab
programs here in the state of Missouri
are you hungry
right now the bats that I have at my
location are all big brown bats these
guys all came into us as little orphaned
hairless pups in the next few weeks
they'll be getting a chance to see if
they can fly and eat and maintain their
weight on their own in the hopes of
releasing them back into the wild you
looking for more there are so many
misconceptions about bats I just wish
that everybody would realize that they
have an integral part of our ecosystem
there's a real sense of pride that we
have helped these bats gain in
population numbers nobody has to Pat me
on the back for it I feel it it's the
thank-you from them as I see many more
and more of them surviving and living
healthy and happy
that's what I'm out for
[Music]
we're here the sanctuary we have our own
motto that we believe in it's saving one
animal may not change the world
but surely for that one animal the world
would change forever
and we fully believe that because we see
it every day my name is Pat Craig I'm
the executive director and founder of
the Wild Animal Sanctuary located in
keansburg Colorado the sanctuary was
started 36 years ago I visited a zoo one
times and I was really surprised to see
all these lions and tigers in the back
kept in tiny little cages and I found
out they were surplus and that they
actually euthanized those animals so I
opened the first sanctuary in the
country for large carnivores
oh come on Mia Bob so in the beginning I
started on the family farm right outside
of Boulder Colorado at the time you know
I dropped out of school and started
working full-time to support the animals
and build more space and go get more
animals we started to get phone calls
from law enforcement agencies who were
finding them in apartments and basements
about 85% of all the animals here were
legal confiscations for people who
either abused them or had them illegally
and the rest either come from zoos
circuses or other places like that that
didn't have them
we have over 420 rescued cardboards
living here and everything from wolves
tigers bears lions leopards mountain
lions you name it I mean there's a lot
of mouths to feed
we feed over 38 thousand pounds of food
a week these animals are absolutely like
my kids just because this is my life
turned into a seven day a week 365 day a
year job that I've been doing for 36
years and you know there is no time to
go anywhere for vacations or anything
else it's all for the animals wasn't
something I expected to do and it had no
idea how monumental I was going to get
but it's been worth it every bit of the
time so I wouldn't never wouldn't have
changed at all
[Music]
a bird in New York City doesn't have it
easy
whether it's flying into a building a
car a bicycle dogs pollution lead poison
this is not nature's natural course we
have interfered with it my name is Rita
McMahon and I'm the co-founder and
director of the wild bird fund New York
City's one and only wildlife
rehabilitation center we take in birds
that anyone has found and we do our best
to make it whole so that it can go back
to the wild the atmosphere at the wild
bird fund is something of a three-ring
circus
there's the ISO room waterfowl room
reception area and downstairs is a whole
nother thing there are a couple 100
Birds down there they may be flying
around in the air as people are
scurrying around cleaning the cages
giving them meds and feeding them we
deal with 135 different species this
past week we had a Canada Goose 7
kestrels a rowdy bunch of juvenile
herring gulls this year 2016 we will
treat well over 4,000 Birds
[Music]
by being in New York City where the
animal is found we are able to save many
more animals they would die before they
could get help in another state or
another County people can come to you by
a subway or bus and they can get the
animal to you faster it's exciting you
never really know who's going to walk
through that door or what they're
holding in that box I was at my store
and I saw the pigeon I saw that he was
like bleeding on the floor like pretty
bad I didn't even know that they took in
pigeons any animal that is picked up is
in really bad shape 50% will die or are
euthanized if we can reduce the
suffering that's a good thing too but
50% go free when the birds better you
try to return it to where it came if
it's an adult bird it might have family
friends it knows where to live the
migratory birds they're just passing
through you're really just trying to put
them in a safe place
so that they can continue their journey
you
[Music]